he had a sense of humor too and it
always played out
and i think he will have learned that
when he was a young soldier
and he will have faced the challenges
and rigors
of the burma campaign and that ferocious
struggle
in which so many people lost their lives
we'll also hear later on the
epitaph readout that's on the kahima
memorial
as right now he is lifted by soldiers
who like him
took their duty to serve the nation and
he'll be born on their soldiers
on their shoulders into the crematorium
at bedford
for this very simple ceremony
the regimental standards have been
lowered by
mr bill swales former reservist with the
4th battalion the yorkshire regiment and
mr david wooley who's come
he's a duke's veteran like sir tom
himself
representing the duke of wellington's
regimental association
and alastair the the words of the
defense secretary ben wallace
today on the military involvement and
the pride of the military to take part
in this
what is a private family funeral in
national emergencies he said
ordinary people do extraordinary things
and inspire us all to pull together
to overcome adversity few will have
heard of seton before this crisis
but his contribution and example now
lives on in all of us
the armed forces are immensely proud to
contribute
to the celebration of his extraordinary
life of service and later on
the last post and an raf flypast
alastair
from the battle of britain flight it was
another part of his
100th birthday when the battle of
britain flight
memorial flight gave their salute to him
and we'll see that again
at the end of the service and here
the salute itself from the dakota with
its markings of the dj landings on its
wings
let's listen
stop still
firing party
14 soldiers from the yorkshire regiment
giving the firing salute
the highest military honor that can be
paid to a soldier
as he is taken to his resting place
inside a family gathered for this
sad moment but at the end of the most
remarkable
lifetime of service which has completely
uplifted a nation
and perhaps with them into that
crematorium comes
the entire support and good wishes
of a nation that was touched by his
brilliant charm his amazing
example and what he did for our national
health service
and to invigorate a nation facing the
challenges and difficulties
of kovid
and alistair just looking at these
images from inside
the crematorium very poignant to see
those
empty pews inside the crematorium
in ordinary times a man who had
had the impact and had captured the
public so much
in the way that captain sir tom moore
had you would expect to see
so many people there to pay their
respects
and yet like so many families this is
a very small very personal affair
and no less poignant and i think that in
so many ways
people have been gathering to support
families
by just prayer or thoughts when those
they've lost have been laid
to rest soldiers will play their part
and place
sir tom moore as their last service to
him
on this catapult for the ceremony to
take place
and then the music will begin with
you'll never walk alone
where we'll hear the voice of captain
sir tom moore
with michael ball and the national
health service voices
you mentioned there some of the music
you'll never walk alone
uh captain sir tom moore becoming the
oldest to receive the uh
number one to achieve a number one in
the uk
and also music from dame vera lynn
a very personal connection there captain
sir tom moore
having watched her perform during his
military service in burma
well just like saton moore has raised
the spirit of the nation
during covid so daim viralin raised it
during the second world war and i think
the two of them represent part of their
own generation
that has been exceptional and that is
why the nation wanted to give them the
very best
and particularly the army too and the
air force on behalf of the armed
services
that he gave so much of his life to